the quadratic expression x squared plus
5x plus c is a perfect square and it can
be factored as x plus d squared
both c and d are positive rational
numbers so what i want to figure out in
this video is what is c given the
information that we we have right over
here what is c going to be equal to and
what is d going to be equal to and like
always pause the video and see if you
can figure it out well let's work
through this together we're saying that
x squared plus 5x plus c can be
rewritten as x plus d squared so let me
write that down so this part
this part x squared plus five x
plus c
we're saying that that could be written
as x plus d squared this is equal to
x plus d squared now we can rewrite x
plus d squared is going to be equal to
x squared plus 2
x
2 let me write 2 dx
2 dx plus
d squared if this step right over here
you find strange i encourage you to
watch the videos on squaring binomials
or on are on perfect square polynomials
either one so you can see the pattern
that this is going to be
x squared
plus two times the product of both of
these terms plus d squared
and so when you look at it like this you
can start you can start to pattern match
a little bit you can say all right
well
5x
right over here
that is going to have to be equal to 2d
and then you can also say that c
is going to have to be equal to
d squared
so
once again we could say 2d is equal to
5. 2d is equal to 5 or that d is equal
to 5
halves so we've figured out what d is
equal to and now we can figure out what
c is because we know that c is c needs
to be equal to d squared
see
that orange color actually
so we know that c is equal to d squared
which is the same thing as 5 half
squared we just figured out what d is
equal to it's going to be 5 half squared
which is going to be 25
over 4. so c is
c is equal to 25 over 4 d is equal to
five halves and we're done